[Music]
there are so many crazy things that we
see on the internet though we start
believing some of them sometimes it's
because we trust our friends and we can
also think that a myth is more
interesting than the truth if you think
that you're one of those people who
don't believe in any ridiculous things
you might be surprised by what you'll
see today make sure you watch our video
until the end to see if you were right
if this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 10 ridiculous
assumptions people still believe today
your facebook status will change privacy
rules if you are one of the 2 billion
monthly active users on Facebook you
have probably seen one of your friends
posting the status and you maybe shared
it too there are different versions but
most of them say that the content of
this profile is private and confidential
information the violation of privacy can
be punished by law then the message says
that all facebook members need to post a
note like this or the website will have
the right to use all their photos and
information it might seem scary and
really serious so we understand why
people are posting this but did anyone
wonder if it was true you can tell your
friends to stop doing this right now
because this status will never make your
profile more private you already
accepted Facebook's rights and
responsibilities and their data policy
when you created your profile
you cannot just break an agreement with
the status because you changed your mind
the only way to protect your information
is by not using facebook at all anyway
anything you post on the Internet is
there forever as people can do whatever
they want with it
the only real way to keep everything
private is to stop using the internet
and do you think that those who posted
this status about privacy will do it we
don't think so
vaccines are dangerous it has been more
than 200 years since vaccines were
invented and they quickly became the
most effective method of preventing
infectious diseases when almost the
whole population is vaccinated it is
possible for a disease to never come
back again or effective very few people
but unfortunately since people think
that vaccines are dangerous and avoid
them more people risk being infected by
H - kids receive almost 30 shots to
boost their immune system it can be
quite scary and this is why many parents
think that there could be important side
effects one of the popular myths is that
vaccines cause autism and
think that it's been proven by a study
published by a British surgeon however
the study has since been completely
discredited for many reasons
so no one should use that as an argument
if people claim that their child is
totally fine even though they haven't
been vaccinated the reason why they
didn't catch the disease is that almost
everyone else is protected the only ones
who should not use the vaccines are
those who won't be able to support it
because of allergies or a medical
condition we understand that people care
a lot about their children's health but
if they look at the facts the right
choice to protect them is vaccination if
you want to watch just one more video
the premium is the platform where you
should go get early access to videos
from the things the taco the trendy the
richest and many other great channels in
one place with ad free browsing click
this link to sign up for free to the
premium and get ready to binge watch
videos from your favorite channels
climate change isn't real if the
President of the United States said it
it must be true right but Donald Trump
already proved many times that we
shouldn't always listen to him he posted
on Twitter that the concept of global
warming was created by and for the
Chinese in order to make us
manufacturing non-competitive and this
is not the only thing he shared with the
population unfortunately this man has a
huge influence on the population and
making them believe that climate change
isn't real could make people stop making
efforts to save the planet we don't know
what it will take for Trump to
understand that climate change is real
but there are already many facts to
prove it
we have seen the temperature rising all
around the world 2015 being the hottest
on record for the third year in a row it
has had an impact on many things as
glaciers are retreating sea levels rose
by almost 8 inches Islands disappeared
and animals changed their habits
if you like to listen to an authority
figure NASA also said there is no
question that increased levels of
greenhouse gases must cause the earth to
warm in response 97% of climate
scientists also confirm that global
warming is happening now climate change
is real and everyone needs to believe it
if we want to take action and protect
the only planet we have ghosts exist we
can't say that these people are right
and we can't say that they are wrong but
we think that we need real proof before
thinking that something actually exists
doesn't stop three out of four Americans
to believe in at least one paranormal
thing according to a Gallup survey from
2005 more than a third of them also said
that they believe in ghosts or spirits
and even though we think that we don't
believe in any of these scary stories we
have to admit that we can all be a
little bit scared if we get lost alone
in the woods at night we all wondered
where this weird sound came from but
there is a reason why we believe in
ghosts it all comes down to how our
brain works according to Barry Markovski
a sociologist at the University of South
Carolina our mind creates patterns when
we don't clearly understand the
information in front of us and when you
believe that there could be a ghost your
brain could make you think that a
strange shadow passing by could be
explained by a spirit people see what
they want to see after all everyone can
be a little ridiculous sometimes and
there is nothing wrong with that we have
to admit that believing in ghosts can be
entertaining when we're visiting a
haunted house evolution never happened
most of us learned about evolution in
class but no matter what many people
don't believe that it actually happened
according to a Gallup survey 42% of
Americans are creationists 31% are
theistic evolutionists and 19% are a
theistic evolutionists there are also a
lot of people who just don't care you've
already learned about evolution in high
school your teacher might even have to
teach you about different theories to
avoid controversy so instead we'll tell
you why people don't want to believe in
the truth no matter what the truth is
people don't believe in the facts they
believe in the leader of the group they
want to belong to you are most likely to
be able to persuade someone if you're
part of the same community that's
because when it comes to survival
belonging to a group is more important
than believing in the truth so if
everyone believed in creationism you
wouldn't want to tell them your theory
about evolution because you wouldn't
want to be rejected people are also
looking for meanings they're not
convinced by the idea that animals and
humans would change over thousands of
years because they don't see any reason
why and religion gives them a reason so
if you want to convince your friend that
evolution exists you want to make sure
that they know that you are part of the
same group and give meaning to science
the moon landing was a hoax it is
already incredible to think that a man
walked on the moon so incredible that
people think that it never happened 40
years after the Apollo 11 moon landing
people started looking
pictures and notice some things that
were strange this was when they started
thinking that the moon landing was
staged by NASA to clean that they walked
on the moon before the Russians winning
the space race in 1969 now six percent
of Americans believe the Apollo moon
landing was faked and five percent are
still undecided according to a Gallup
poll this theory became so popular that
it had to be debunked many times by
scientists for example people said that
the American flag seems to be flying in
a breeze and it wouldn't be possible as
there is no air on the moon space flight
historian Roger Launius explained that
it's because the astronaut just placed
it there and that's why it was still
moving in another picture you can see
the only two astronauts who walked on
the moon and no sign of any camera
astronomer Phil Plait explained that the
camera was mounted on their chests when
people asked why they can't see the
stars in the sky he explains that the
picture was taken too fast to see the
background no matter what conspiracists
say there will be an explanation because
the moon landing did happen alike will
save the world if you're a Facebook user
you have probably seen many pages asking
you to like their picture to help a
random cause like someone suffering from
a disease or an animal that needs a
shelter you can also see people who will
do something if they get X number of
likes you probably didn't think that it
would really change anything but a like
is free and takes only a second so you
thought why not like this picture
actually liking a picture to save the
world could be a really bad idea
it's a dangerous scam called like
farming people on Facebook make sure
that they will get your attention to get
more likes and shares and the more you
interact with the picture the more your
friends will see it too if you still
don't think that there's anything wrong
with that
wait until you see what they use this
attention for after they get enough
likes they change the post to something
else
these pictures are then used to spread
malware these people can also collect
your personal information create more
scams and sell it on the black market we
know that it is easy to like everything
that you see on social media but if
someone you don't know or a page that is
not associated with any real
organization encourages you to like
their post the best thing to do is to
ignore it
gays can choose to become straight we
still don't know why people are gay we
just know that there is nothing wrong
with that however some people think that
it is a choice and that a gay person can
choose to be
straight which is a really harmful
assumption anyway this theory doesn't
make any sense at all why would people
choose to be gay many members of the
LGBT community said that they once
wished they were straight because things
would be easier this way they would not
have to face rejection prejudices and
discrimination even though most of them
are now proud to be gay
they certainly don't believe that it was
a good or bad decision that's just who
they are if you're straight just try to
have a gay feeling for a moment and
you'll see that it is simply impossible
media didn't help when they showed women
kissing another girl just for attention
it is also difficult to portray someone
who is bisexual as people might see them
as sometimes gay or straight and
therefore think that it is a choice
but in real life we can say that love is
not a choice
hate is so as long as scientists can't
argue on a reason why people are gay why
not listen to what they say they are the
best witnesses to say that they were
born this way someone actually said that
we love posting quotes from our favorite
artists but did you know that most of
them never actually said that one of the
most popular actresses for fake quotes
is probably Marilyn Monroe remember when
she said give a girl the right shoes and
she can conquer the world it's actually
Bette Midler who said that people also
think that she said to all the girls
that think you're fat because you're not
a size zero you're the beautiful one
it's society who's ugly it can't be her
quote because Size Zero didn't exist at
that time an artist thought that these
fake quotes were ridiculous and decided
to make fun of the situation she wrote
quotes from Hitler on pictures of Taylor
Swift to pretend that she said that the
quotes were actually nice including I
can fight for something that I love love
only what I respect and respect only
what I know
we have to admit that we would have
fallen for this one too when she posted
it on Pinterest her artwork went viral
and spread around the internet people
thinking that they were talking about
Taylor Swift unfortunately when people
understood that Hitler was the actual
person who said that the young woman who
created the pictures was in trouble but
it is still proof that you shouldn't
always believe what you see the earth is
flat you might think that everyone knows
that the earth is round now but no
matter what people keep surprising us
with their beliefs Tila Tequila wrote on
Twitter why are all the buildings in NYC
standing straight up if earth was round
than some of the buildings would have a
slight tilt hashtag Flat Earth the
rapper b.o.b even wrote a song about the
earth being flat people argue that if
our planet was round airplane pilots
would have to constantly readjust their
controls to make sure that they don't
fly into space water would also be
wobbling all over the place we
understand why these people are confused
mathematics has become so complicated
that they only trust what they see with
their own eyes so let's talk about
something that they actually see when
you look at pictures of the Earth from
space you can clearly see that the
planet is round we have also heard of
many people traveling all around the
world so you won't be falling into space
anywhere sorry members of the Flat Earth
Society
your theory might be nothing but wrong
is there any crazy thing that you used
to believe don't be shy to tell us what
you think in the comment section down
below we love to hear what you think and
that's it for 10 ridiculous assumptions
people still believe today for more
stories like this make sure to watch 10
amazing pictures they won't show you in
history books thanks for watching
[Music]